you see
this is where
the attraction starts it starts here in
the non-physical world now this is a
mind game you must understand the mind
if you're really going to make it happen
and when you study this and start to
understand it
then you attract according to the
vibration you're in and you'll start to
understand that you control the
vibration your brain is electronic
switching station as you activate brain
cells you alter the vibration you're in
as you alter the vibration you alter
what you attract into your life
so you see
you've got to understand how to control
the vibration
and you can do that and i'm going to
show you i'm going to give you a quick
lesson in it
and when you get it everything will
change way back in 1934 the same year
that simeon curling perfected the form
of photography where you can photograph
mass and photograph the energy leaving
the body there was a doctor down in san
antonio texas dr thurman fleet he wanted
to understand the mind and he wanted to
understand paradigms see paradigm is a
mind program it's a program in your
subconscious mind that's controlling
your behavior think of this for a moment
you already know how to do better than
you're doing but you're not doing it
everybody does
see the part of our mind that knows
things and the part that controls our
behavior two different parts that's
right so let's talk about your power
your mind and your paradigm the paradigm
is the programming in the subconscious
mind that controls our behavior
now fleet understood this
and he he was very much into holistic
health and
very much into metaphysics and he said
nobody's ever seen the mind the mind is
an activity it's not a thing and no
one's ever seen it he said i am going to
eliminate confusion i'm going to make a
picture of the mind and he drew a
picture he says just use your
imagination and this becomes the mind
now look at that
do you know that this is the most
magnificent idea i've ever come across
in 55 years of studying ideas i've got a
beautiful library here i have another
one in the house i'm in my studio right
now
and we take we take that circle and we
draw a line across and then we say
that's the conscious mind that's the
subconscious mind and then there's the
body now i want you to really play with
this that is without question the most
valuable idea i've ever learned
leland valvandewal who's gone now god
bless him he shared that with me see i
had been studying with no formal
education no business experience my
income went from nothing to over a
million dollars a year i was cleaning
offices i just wanted to earn some extra
money but i started to use this
information and the business started to
grow i was living in england and
wondering how did i do this
i knew
that i wasn't that smart i've been
raised to believe if you're going to a
lot of money you've got to be really
smart i wasn't that smart but i was
earned a lot of money i was raised to
believe if you don't have a good formal
education you'll never get a good job
well i didn't have any formal education
i had two months high school i didn't
have a good job i owned the company
i did not believe that there was an
emotional capricious god that reached
out and blessed me
and i didn't think i was lucky so i made
up my mind i was going to figure out why
i changed and i started to study and i
never stopped i was living in chicago i
left my business and i went to work with
earl nightingale lloyd conant because i
knew that they knew something i wanted
to know
and i was working there and somebody
told me about a guy in vancouver british
columbia so i jumped on a plane and off
i went as soon as he opened his mouth
like that i knew he knew what he was
talking about
when the meeting was over
it was a couple of days i went and asked
him i said could i spend a couple hours
with you and i remember him looking at
his watch and he's saying i'd like to
spend a couple hours with you but he's
not going to catch a plane i said i
gotta catch a plane too i don't mean
right now he's where are you going i
sang going home he said where do you
live and i said chicago we said what are
you doing out here i said i come out
here you speak i think he was impressed
that i flew so far
to listen to him
he said i'm not going to be in chicago
anytime in the near future but i'm going
to be in toronto and i said i'm actually
from toronto i'll come over there and
see it's only an hour away and so i flew
over the two of us sat down which was
going to be for a couple hours we were
there for about three days
and he started to show me things about
the mind everything i had studied for
over 10 years was all coming together
and if you follow what i'm teaching if
you really listen to what i'm saying
everything you've studied is going to
come together
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn some of the
law of attraction secrets
enjoy
secret number two is be open to
possibilities with rhonda byrne can you
share what is the law of attraction and
is it possible that anyone can truly
achieve what they want if they use it
effectively and also part two of this
question what's the quickest way
to hold you back
from the law of attraction
so one of the ways that i talk about the
law of attraction or the secret is is
sort of in a different way from the way
i used to speak about it because i'm
always looking how can i make it even
simpler and and i mean basically that
work talks about the power of the mind
and the power of thought
um to create our physical world and
material world and then the greatest
secret takes that to a whole new level
actually
and so then you really get to see that
oh my gosh it's super easy to create
anything i want like really so easy
because if we have a belief it's hard
then it's going to be hard you know and
so
and so it has everything to do with our
mind and what we believe
and so if we believe a thought it will
manifest end of story
so if we believe we are deserving of
great love then we will manifest it if
we believe we're going to be poor we're
going to stay poor if we believe we
don't deserve something then it's not
going to come to us
and you know it's interesting because
because uh for all of us you know and
we've been conditioned you know i mean
you were very fortunate because you you
had a
a childhood where
you were
mind was opened and you were opened and
your heart was opened and that's the
biggest biggest thing
is to open yourself to the possibility
that everything isn't the way it appears
to be
and so even if you can just open
yourself to that possibility just for a
moment you can pick up it all the next
day you can take it all with you the
next day that it's all real and
everything that you're seeing but if you
just for a moment open to the
possibility that things might not be the
way that you think they are
then you have the greatest opportunity
to really discover something incredible
how incredible you are so
so with the secret yeah i describe it
really and so i really simplify it and
the law of attraction because i would
say to anybody if you would just think
about what you want
that's all you'd ever get in your life
it's as simple as that secret number
three is clear blockages within you with
big sean one of the things i've had to
do in my life is clear
some of the blockages that i've had and
you know
all in different ways all through
different people and that's something
that i may want to get more detailed in
with people too because people are going
to say well how do i clear these
blockages within me and there are many
many ways and many people that peoples
that i've met with that have been able
to you know help me and you know i used
to have a worryman of money was one of
them just like you can inherit
your parents hair or you can inherit
their eyes or you can inherit there you
know i remember my dad used to be like i
used to smile just like you did you know
so you can inherit a smile you can also
inherit someone's
fears you can also inherit someone's
beliefs that aren't in alignment with
you know your own and you feel very
conflicted
uh you can inherit
uh just a lot of you can inherit uh pain
you can inherit racism
and you'd be like well i'm not a racist
person but i know i know someone who's
like bro i'm not a racist person but
then
they call every black person a kid
you know he's good that's a good kid and
i'm like
you gotta watch yourself a little bit
man that's like
you know just pay attention to that
because you don't refer to people who
are who look like you as a kid
and so you might refer to somebody who's
a kid that's the same age almost the
same age as you you know so it's like
you inherit these things you may not
even realize it right and
it's important to just do the work on
yourself because to push the next it's
like also breaking generational curses
it's like
i broke one of the blockages i had and
now my family uh we are living
we are getting more of our dreams uh my
mom is doing things that she never
thought she would do my dad my brother
you know um
we grew up in debt essentially and we i
had to break that that was one of the
blocks i had to break was uh the block
of month of not be scared to have money
feel like there's a scarcity of money
and it's not you know it's all just
energy right and you can have as much
energy as needed
and
uh
to clear all these blocks but
um to get back to my point
it is so important to go through these
blocks and these traumas
because when you pass it on to not only
just the next generation you pass it on
to the people around you your friends
your family you know you are you are the
company you keep
and the more
like-minded and better you are the the
better everyone around you is including
your family right and you guys can have
the opportunity to
do anything that is possible anything
you want any any empire any business any
ownership things that you didn't even
know was imaginable but it all starts
with you working on yourself and that's
the importance of
you know the traumas it's almost like
why would i want to correct you know
cancer runs in our family breast cancer
runs in our family why would i want to
correct that well you want to correct
that so you don't pass it on
and you know the vibration of cancer is
a low vibration you know what i'm saying
so
you know
uh it's important to take care of
ourselves and get rid of that trauma but
okay that was beaut but i'm so glad you
went there yeah i'm so happy you went
there because that the idea of being
aware of what we're inheriting
is so important especially when you when
that we are aware of we inherit what we
wear and how we think and how we look
but then
how we behave how we communicate how we
talk to people how we think about people
yeah how we think about women how we
think about men now
oh that's a good one how you think about
women and men yeah you know that's
another thing or or them how you think
about trans how do you think about lgbtq
like
like ever just how we think about other
i'm so glad you went there i just want
to say that i'm so happy you took us on
that yeah i can just imagine like aliens
or people from another world being like
man these people really tripped that
they
have different shades of
skin they really be like issues they
really kill each other over this like
you know i've never seen a cow look at
another cow and be like you're a brown
kyle you're a
black and white cow i don't want to be
around you like nah they don't know it's
like you know and it makes me realize
that like if we
kill each other and hate each other over
things like that or who we love right or
things that even have nothing to do with
us
then i wonder how we would handle an
extraterrestrial or an alien or really
something that is really different like
you know i always i'm like maybe that's
why the government or whoever doesn't
ever want to really break it to humanity
because who how are we going to react
you know but that's a whole other
conversation
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there secret number four stop doubting
yourself with ashley graham a lot of
people say that manifestation is like
lying to yourself or magic
do you think that just like having
conversations about what you want in
life is magic
or lying to yourself none of it is fake
all of it is real if you if you want
something you can have it
and i'm not like you know i'm not one of
these people that's like on a stage like
giving you a notebook and having you
stay for a week and putting you through
trial and errors and all these things
what i'm just telling you is if you
speak it if you write it and if you put
action behind it you can have it that's
not magic that's common sense okay so
how i learned about manifestation is
kind of funny because it was when the
secret first came out okay do not judge
me okay
we all know about the secret i was an
oprah fan she put it on her show and we
all geeked out
and i must have been 18 and we had all
go gone over to my friend's house and we
were like okay the secret we just
watched oprah and we like got the movie
and we got the book and we started
putting vision boards together
and i had never done that before but
what it did was it started getting me
excited about my future and what i
actually wanted instead of just saying i
want to be successful i want to be rich
i want to be in love it actually helped
me understand details about how to ask
for what i wanted every nothing was
vague and nothing was too broad i
actually kind of honed in on different
aspects of my life so for example on one
vision board i had a big house
um one that i loved i had money signs
kind of like all dripping all over each
other i would put like an actual dollar
bill and i would put a comma and like
add zeros to it i put sports illustrated
a woman speaking like that um with a red
carpet under her and a pedestal um that
would represent ted talks a lingerie
brand i put a makeup brand then i put
that corkboard in my bedroom
so that it would face me so that when i
would wake up and when i would go to bed
it would be one of the last things that
i would see here's the thing i didn't
want to like put myself in such a box
but if there is something that you want
to work with that's so specific to you
put it up there put it on i mean ted
talk i was so specific i wanted to do a
ted talk and i did it sports illustrated
i wanted to shoot for sports illustrated
i wanted a cover but i will let you guys
know these things take time and this
vision board specifically took me three
years you can write down in a journal
exactly
what you want you can categorize it i
mean literally there's no right or wrong
way to do this it's just about the
action and about doing it for yourself
what is it that you know that you could
do what is something that maybe could
happen my track record with my vision
board is like you know pretty good part
of me feels like it's really good
because i don't keep what my goals are
to just myself i talk about them with
the people that work for me that work
around me um i'm not just keeping a
secret
that
get it a secret don't just keep the
secret talk about it in talking about
what you want and what your goals are
and and what your dreams are people want
to help you people want to come in and
and give you a helping hand whether it's
just a piece of advice or um a leg up or
you know
whatever alone whatever it is that
you're looking for if you're manifesting
all of these big dreams and you have all
these big goals but you're going behind
your own back and talking to yourself in
the mirror and saying
god you really suck and you really are
dumb and
you really need to get it together you
have nothing going on for yourself
what are you doing
not only are you blocking your own
blessings but you're blocking your
future you are the roadblock to what it
is that you are actually trying to
manifest make sure you're talking well
to yourself and about yourself because
all of that has to do with what it is
your dreams and your goals are remember
to congratulate yourself when you reach
your goal because that's the biggest
thing to be able to look back
and see what your achievements are and
to not be constantly looking forward to
what have i not done where am i going
again remember to look back
and say you did a great job secret
number five develop certainty with mary
kate everyone wants to manifest things
fast we are in a society where
everything can happen instantly remember
the old days where you had to go to a
library to learn about something or
research about something anything you
were curious about you had to go to the
library and actually look it up and now
we can literally have the answer to any
question that pops into our mind within
30 seconds or less through a smartphone
times have changed a lot we expect
things immediate and fast and of course
the same applies to manifesting we think
of something we want we ask for it we
hold the space we follow the steps and
then we want it right now and i totally
get it that's normal based on the way
we're programmed in society it's the
instant gratification that we are
programmed to expect
but when it comes to manifesting
time really is an illusion
because everything you desire is already
here and it already exists
you just have to align with it and
attract it
typically what i see with a lot of
clients and even personal friends is
that they follow a few steps and they
think they did everything correctly but
then when it doesn't show up right away
or by the deadline that they set they
panic or get frustrated or just give up
but the thing about manifesting is that
the magic truly happens when it looks
like that thing isn't happening and
isn't gonna show up and then the very
last second it shows up anyway there is
this beauty and power in magic in
creation so let's get into this powerful
manifesting hack that i swear by but
also let me be clear it's not up to you
to control the timing or force anything
to happen based on what you think is
best
it's more about allowing
but this hack will make your
manifestation show up much more quickly
than if you hadn't used this so here it
goes i always say what you expect is
what you attract
because expectations are a fundamental
force in what you experience
think about all of the expectations you
have on a daily basis
you expect to wake up maybe at a certain
time maybe not
you expect to have coffee or tea or eat
breakfast or not you expect to maybe go
to work or you have a morning workout
you expect to eat at a certain time be
home at a certain time go to bed at a
certain time you expect to see certain
people talk to certain people experience
certain things throughout your day and
in turn that creates your reality these
are all expectations that you've created
based on your routine
but imagine if you expected the thing
that you want as being real what if you
were able to shift into a certain
energetic frequency to attract much
quicker
this is what i want to show you how to
do right now
so here's how it all works and what to
do
the way this hack works is by shifting
energies and changing your expectations
because what you expect is what you
attract i'll be saying this a lot
because i have to drive this one home
it's so important what you expect is
what you attract so in order to do this
manifesting hack you're gonna have to
grab a paper and pen and let's get
started the first thing you're going to
do is write down the words i am certain
followed by whatever it is that you
intend to manifest and i mean actually
write it don't just type this on your
computer don't just say this in your
mind in order for this manifesting hack
to truly work you have to write it down
on paper so you're going to write down
the words i am certain and then insert
the thing that you intend to manifest
but do it in present tense it is so
important that you actually write this
because there is power and scientific
proof that writing things down helps
solidify in your mind so don't skip this
step get off your chair go get that
paper and pen and actually write the
words i am certain followed by the
intention of what you want and make sure
you write this in present tense that's
extremely important to note so for
example i am certain that i have blank i
am certain that blank is mine i am
certain that i have more money than i
know what to do with i am certain that i
have the most amazing supportive loving
partner i am certain that this is mine
so you write down the words i am certain
followed by a statement of the thing
that you intend to manifest in present
tense as if it's already here and that
you're certain of it
and after you write it down i want you
to sit in the feeling and the energy of
being certain that it's yours for as
long as you need and this feeling of
certainty can feel different for each
person
maybe it just feels like this wave of
comfort and relief that you are so
certain of it
that you don't have to worry about when
and how just feel the feelings of being
100 totally certain that it's going to
happen and it's so obvious that you
can't imagine it not happening just like
how you were totally certain of the
things that you expect throughout your
day explore the feeling of certainty
that this thing will for sure happen no
matter what what does that feel like to
you
and i know that you probably want an
exact amount of time to sit in this
feeling but the amount of time that you
need is different for each and every
person it's based on your thoughts and
your beliefs and your resistance about
this thing that you want it'll determine
how long you need to stay in this
feeling so i can't give you an exact
answer of like 10 minutes 20 minutes an
hour
do what feels best for you you will know
how long to do it based on how you feel
so trust that and trust yourself when
you use this manifesting hack you are
tapping into the same energetic
frequency of the thing that you want and
therefore you are attracting it much
more quickly
the feeling of certainty has a really
powerful energetic force behind it
because it shapes your physical reality
so if you are putting out the energy of
certainty that you know and expect it
fully that it will show up it sets forth
an activation of your desire did you
know that there are actually six
principles that when used in a specific
order create an activation for your
desire to show up in your reality yes
this is really how it works and it
really is that simple and i've developed
an entire system that shows you exactly
what to do when to do it and how inside
of the manifesting activation system
this system works for each and
everything that you intend to manifest
using a combination of quantum physics
energy work subconscious programming and
mindset work designed to clear
resistance shift your energy and create
new beliefs and expectations about what
you get to have it's truly
groundbreaking and the results are
incredible and secret number six the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is organize your mind with satguru
a well established mind
a mind which is in a state of samyukti
is referred to as a kulper fiction
if you organize your mind
to a certain level of organization
it in turn organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything gets organized in the
direction
once all these four dimensions of you
your physical body
your mind your emotion and
the fundamental life energies are
organized in one direction
once you're like this
anything that you wish happens without
even lifting a little finger actually
it would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want if you
organize these four dimensions
in one direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction
it is like you want to travel somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance
so
organizing our minds
and
internal organizing the whole system
and these four basic dimensions of who
you are right now in one direction if
you do this you are a kalpa workshop
yourself
anything that you wish will happen
but right now if you look at your lives
everything that you have wished for till
now if it happens you are finished
everything and everybody that you have
desired for if all of that lands up in
your house today could you live with
that
so if you want to become empowered it is
also important that you become
responsible as to what you ask for and
what you don't
right now the world situation is just
this we are hugely empowered with
technology
today it doesn't take six six billion
people to destroy this planet one man by
pressing the wrong button can destroy
the whole planet
when we are empowered like this it's
very important
that our physical action
emotional action
mental action and energy actions are
controlled and properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive
right now that is our problem the
technology which is supposed to make our
life beautiful and easy has become the
source of all the problem that we are
destroying the very basis
of our life which is the planet
so what should have been a boon we are
making a curse out of it
what has brought incredible
levels of comfort and convenience to us
in the last
100 years or so
has also become a threat to our life
simply because
we are not
conscious action we are in a compulsive
state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means
moving from
a compulsive state of activity to a
conscious state of activity
you might have heard of people
for whom they asked for something and
beyond all expectations it came true to
true for them
generally this happens to people who are
in faith
now
let's say you want to build a house
if you start thinking
oh i want to build a house to build a
house i need 50 lakhs but i have only 50
rupees in my pocket not possible not
possible not possible
the moment you say not possible you're
also saying i don't want it
so on one level you're creating a desire
that you want something on another level
you're saying i don't want it so in this
conflict it may not happen
someone who has some faith
in a god or in a temple or whatever
who is her simple mind faith works only
for those people who are simple-minded
thinking people people who are too much
thinking for them it never works
a child-like person
who has a simple faith in his god or his
temple or whatever
he goes to the temple and says shiva i
want a house i don't know how you must
make it from me
now in his mind there are no negative
thoughts will it happen will it not
happen is it possible is it not possible
these things are completely removed by
the simple act of faith
now he believes shiva will do it for him
and it will happen
so is she going to come and build your
house no i want you to understand god
will not lift his little finger for you
what you refer to as god
is a source of creation
as a creator
he has done a phenomenal job there is no
question about
could you think of a better creation
than this
is it
in anybody's imagination to think
anything better than what is there right
now
so as a creator he has done his job
wonderfully well
but if you want life to happen the way
you want it because right now the very
crux of your happiness and your
well-being is this
if at all if you're unhappy
the only and only reason why you're
unhappy is life is not happening the way
you think it should happen
that's all it is
so if life is not happening the way you
think it should happen
you're unhappy if life happens the way
you think it should happen you are happy
it's as simple as that
so if life has to happen the way you
think it should happen first of all
how you think
with
how much focus you think
how much
stability is there in your thought
and how much reverberance is there in
the thought process will determine
whether your thought will become a
reality or is it just an empty thought
or
how you do not create any impediments
for your thought by creating negative
thought process
is something possible or not possible it
is destroying humanity
what is possible and not possible is not
your business it's nature's business
your business is just to strive for what
you want
right now you're sitting here
if i ask you two simple questions
[Music]
i want you to just look at this and
answer this
right now from where you're sitting can
you just fly off you say no
right now from where you're sitting can
you get up and walk you'll say yes
what is the basis of this
why
you say no to flying and yes to walking
because past experience of life many
times you've gotten up and walked
never did you fly off
or in other words you are using the past
experience of life as a basis for
deciding whether something is possible
or not possible
or in other words
you have decided that what has not
happened till now cannot happen in your
life in
future this is a disgrace to humanity
and the human spirit
what has not happened till now on this
planet can happen tomorrow human beings
are capable of making it happen tomorrow
so what is possible and what is not
possible is not your business
that is nature's business nature will
decide that
you just
see what is it that you really want and
strive for that
and if your thought is created in a
powerful way without any negativity
without any negative thoughts bringing
down the intensity of the thought
process
it will definitely manifest
the law of attraction definitely works
most people just get it wrong most
people only focus on the thinking part
and not the most important part which is
the action right law of attraction it's
the last five letters that matter a c t
i o a c t i o n six the last six letters
that matter action action action
thinking about it alone is not enough so
it's the two parts you get an idea you
want something into your life you want
to manifest something amazing you want
success in your business you want a
happy relationship awesome you want to
speak on giant stages whatever the thing
is that you want in your life awesome
you have a vision board amazing just the
fact that you're thinking about it
and believing in it is already a big
step ahead of where most people are most
people live in a negative zone most
people feel like their life is hopeless
that they can't make a change that
they're stuck where they are and guess
what happens they stay exactly stuck
where they are right what you focus on
ends up becoming your reality so yes
you're gonna focus on your new goal your
new habit the new thing that you want
into your life amazing you believe that
it's possible amazing you're putting up
a vision board with it on your wall
amazing you're researching and watching
videos like this every day amazing
that's great that's the first starting
point but nothing happens until you take
action
nothing happens until you take action
thinking alone is not enough
again it puts you ahead of most of the
most of the world puts you way ahead of
them but you're still just going to be
this super smart super ambitious person
sitting at home not achieving your goals
you have to do something i look at my
youtube channel as an example uh my main
channel i want to get to 10 million
subscribers that's my next goal right we
hit one we hit two i gotta hit 10. uh at
the rate that we're growing it's not
fast enough like it's gonna take me way
too many years to make it happen so i
need to apply more pressure against it
so
part of what i look at every day now in
my morning routine is i want to hit my
goal i want to get 10 million
subscribers on my youtube channel right
i want to be you know one of the first
thought leaders experts business person
to have 10 million subscribers on a
youtube channel it's my next goal great
writing that down every day doesn't make
sure that it's going to happen what am i
doing
right writing it down can lead to
thoughts that then lead to action but
what am i actually doing well i'll tell
you what i'm doing now
one of the biggest things i'm working on
now big new initiative for my team is
i've got 6 000 public videos on my main
channel and
i told my team
this week i want to go back and update
all of the thumbnails in all of the
titles across all my videos
that's a lot of videos right that's 6
000 videos imagine doing split tests on
all of those videos
i asked for 10 a day and so two key
people on my team are working together
to come up with what the title is going
to be and then the other one's doing the
graphic design to create the thumbnails
maybe it works the first time but maybe
it doesn't
and it's a big ambitious project if you
think about it we got 6000 videos 10
videos a day
you know in a year if we did it for 10
videos every day we're just over half of
those videos assuming that they all work
out which they won't
so this is our test and if it works
awesome i might have that become
somebody's full-time job so that we can
do 20 slit tests a day 40 split tests a
day a hundred split deaths a day i don't
know
but it's happening to action right so it
starts with the idea if you have the
idea but you're not taking action you
won't get results if you just have the
action but you have no idea you're
running around with a chicken with your
head cut off you're going in circles
without any clear direction
most people
think too much and don't do enough
that's most people some people do too
much and don't think enough some people
need more planning but in general most
people are over planners
and so watching this video alone is not
enough
it's a great start it might boost your
motivation it might give you an idea to
go off and try watching my content
watching dan lok's content alone is not
enough it's the essential first piece of
the ingredient it's it's essential
surrounding yourself with people who
build you up who make you believe who
give you ideas you can act on that allow
you to feel like your goals are are
possible that your dreams are within
reach is super important i do it every
day it's why i create all these channels
i think you should too you'll notice a
difference in how you think every single
day if you are creating content and
consuming content that builds you up
but then yourself to go take the second
step
it's why after every video i have a
question of the day or i have a
three-point landing question because i
want you to take action you need to
teach yourself that after every video
you watch up to every podcast you listen
to after every book that you read
but that's not enough you have to do
something about it i'd rather you watch
fewer videos read fewer books listen to
fewer podcasts consume less
if you're taking action on the ideas
that come to you because most people are
just professional
consumers
and it's great that you're consuming
educational content because most people
are just consuming stupid content right
you hate your life so you go watch
netflix all day when you get home for
five hours and then go to sleep right
you're a professional consumer but
you're consuming
uh wasteful content just entertaining
content
so you've already taken a step above
right you're consuming educational
content that's the next step you're
consuming educational content amazing
but still that alone is not enough what
separates the people go off and achieve
their dreams from the ones who just have
things on a vision board is that last
step of taking action so you're not
allowed anymore your new standards
you're raising your standards for
yourself you are not allowed anymore to
watch a video to read a book to listen
to a podcast to consume anything without
taking some kind of immediate action
towards it immediate action immediate
action it may not be the big thing
if you want to hit a million subscribers
on your youtube channel great what's
immediate action film a video today make
an improvement to your thumbnail today
reach out for an interview for someone
today right immediate action teach
yourself that as soon as you get an idea
you do something about it because that's
the only thing that you're missing the
only thing that you're missing is
momentum if you're watching this channel
you believe in your talent you know
you're capable of more you've got big
goals big ambitions big dreams for
yourself the only thing you're missing
is momentum so to activate the law of
attraction pay attention to the last six
letters action and start doing something
about it if you organize your mind to a
certain level of organization
it in turn organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything it's organized in the
direction
once all these four dimensions of you
your physical body
your mind your emotion and
the fundamental life energies are
organized in one direction once you are
like this
anything that you wish happens without
even lifting a little finger actually
it would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want if you
organize these four dimensions
in one direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction
it is like you want to travel somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance it's very
important
that our physical action
emotional action
mental action and energy actions are
controlled and properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive
right now that is our problem the
technology which is supposed to make our
life beautiful and easy has become the
source of all the problem that we are
destroying the very basis of our life
which is the planet
so what should have been a boon we are
making a curse out of it
what has brought incredible
levels of comfort and convenience to us
in the last
100 years or so has also become a threat
to our life
simply because
we are not
conscious action we are in a compulsive
state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means
moving from a compulsive state of
activity to a conscious state of
activity we live in a world that
reinforces a scarcity mentality and that
mentality keeps us an energy of lack it
keeps us from attracting the career path
that we want the abundance that we want
and allowing us to really live our
purpose
there are six common blocks to abundance
and we all experience them in different
ways
the first block is a lack mentality and
when we have a belief system around lack
we create more lack in our life we all
have stories from our childhood how our
parents experienced abundance or how
they didn't and those stories start to
create a inner dialogue that gets us
into a vibration of feeling like we
don't have enough
and if we feel like we don't have enough
we do a lot of work to try to prove to
the world that we are enough
the second block is the belief system
that there's not enough to go around
we often overwork to try to get it all
we're constantly trying to get get get
because we don't believe that there is
enough it makes us feel like we have to
work so hard to get what we want and
that effort and that anxiety is really
really blocking the natural order which
is the flow abundance
the third block is the block of
comparison
we
literally just turn on our social media
and we're immediately into compare
compare compare
and comparing blocks are attracting
power because it focuses us on what we
don't have rather than feeling good and
feeling faith
the fourth block is the need to win in
the place of having fun because when
we're so focused on winning we lose
track of what it feels like to enjoy the
process and that winning can really get
in our way of allowing
the fifth block is the fear of rejection
when we fear rejection we don't take
action and in effect we create more lack
in our life because we're not actually
trying we're not actually putting out
our desires we're not actually taking
that leap towards what we want
but it's important to understand that
rejection can be protection
when we have some form of rejection show
up in our life it's the universe guiding
us to something better
and the final block is the fear of
judgment
you may be so terrified of being judged
that you don't take that action you
don't show up for your dreams you don't
even contemplate a world where you could
do the thing that you've been dreaming
of you're so afraid of judgment because
you think that other people won't
support you but what's really important
to recognize is that if you're afraid of
what other people think and how they
won't support you it's typically a sign
that you are not supporting yourself now
that you know the six blocks to
abundance i want to give you my methods
for clearing those blocks so that you
can allow abundance to flow to you it's
called the universal abundance method
the first step of the universal
abundance method is to protect your
desires so you can stay in alignment
so if you have a really important desire
something that you care about something
that you want to manifest into your life
it's extremely valuable not to talk
about it with anyone who might resist it
step two is to focus on giving rather
than getting
the more we are in that service
mentality
the more positively the universe
responds to us this puts you into an
abundance mentality quickly because the
more you give the more you will receive
and step three is to want more for
others
it is an opportunity for us to see that
we all can succeed we all can have
abundance in our life and the second you
start to intend for others to have more
of what you want for yourself you start
to feel good you start to feel like
you're contributing you start to feel
like you're connecting and you're no
longer comparing or jealous and you're
no longer separating yourself from
others redirect your focus from what can
i get to how do i feel and really allow
that feeling of abundance to propel you
forward and create momentum and allow
the universe to bring to you all that
you desire here's what everybody gets
wrong about manifesting
everybody at least kind of in the mass
market what you're trained to think
about when you think about manifesting
is vision boards
and when you hear the word vision boards
you think about the big stuff
should you have big dreams of course you
should should you dream of building a
mansion on the ocean if that's your
thing yes should you dream of the log
cabin yes if you want a lamborghini or
the new ford bronco should you put yeah
yes yes yes if you want the family if
you want the body should you think about
yeah absolutely here's where everybody
goes wrong
you
dream about the end you make this
gorgeous collage of all this stuff that
has nothing to do with your current life
that literally as you're sitting in your
studio apartment with the cat box that
hasn't been changed in two weeks no food
in the fridge no fruit in the fridge and
you're looking for a job and you're
staring at a mansion going someday
it's going to make you feel like a loser
because the gap between where you are
and where you want to go it seems
insurmountable
and so what happens based on the
research is when you only visualize the
end game louis it's demotivating at
first it's really fun to like have a
bottle of wine and make your like
collage i'm gonna visualize i'm slap
this up there's my vision board it's a
fabulous law of attraction baby come on
come on think about it it's going to
come to me
okay i've been doing this for two days
i'm not i'm still in this apartment with
the cat box that needs to be changed
the way to visualize properly is to
visualize the bridge
between where you are
and where you need to go the bridge yes
and particularly
the horrible stuff
so let's use your example of the
marathon
the vision board would be lewis crossing
the battle exactly
yes i did it exactly
that will not help you because when you
hit mile 13 on the actual race and it is
sleeting range you say why am i doing
this yes and it feels nothing like that
thing on your vision board you're going
to start a negative dialogue i can't do
this my knees hurt this is not what i
thought it was going to be i'm not ready
for this i didn't train for this i'm
running new york i trained in l.a are
you running in europe l.a okay good well
then at least you're trained in the
right weather so on and on and on and
you are going to tank yourself
what you do by visualizing the bridge is
you train your nervous system
and your mind
to do the hard work so you should
visualize
not crossing the finish line but what is
it like to be at mile 12 when your
batteries run out on your earbuds yeah
i'm serious and you keep going
what's it like when your shoelace breaks
and now your heel is lifting and you're
starting to get a blood blister at mile
17. what's it feel like when you wake up
and it is pouring rain and you visualize
yourself running anyway
that way when you visualize the work
you are preparing your body for it so
you're not resistant to it when it comes
first of all every time we have a
thought we make a chemical and and if
you have
uh
an unlimited thought you will feel
unlimited and if you have a
self-depreciating thought you'll feel
unworthy and your brain instantaneously
fires circuits
that signal another part of the brain to
release peptides or chemical messengers
that signal hormonal centers
and when we get that arousal from the
thought that we think
those thoughts sometimes weaken the
response weakens the physical body so
it turns out that
the emotions that are created from the
thoughts are the signaling mechanisms of
the body thoughts of the language of the
brain
and feelings are the language of the
body and how we think and how we feel
creates our state of being
so it turns out that the thoughts based
in the stress hormones
based in survival those are the thoughts
that begin to push the genetic buttons
that create disease in other words a
person wakes up in the morning
and the brain is a record of the past
the first thing they do when they wake
up in the morning is they start thinking
about their problems
and those problems are memories that are
etched in the brain that are connected
to certain people certain objects uh
certain things at certain times and
places so if you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny the moment you think about your
problems you're thinking in the past
right
now every one of those problems
has an emotion associated with them
because we've experienced them so the
moment you remember your problems
now you feel unhappy now you feel
anxious now you feel fear
so the moment we feel those emotions it
takes a thought and a feeling
a memory or an image an emotion a
stimulus and a response and we start
conditioning the body emotionally into
the past now the body
is so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion
and the emotion that person is
fabricating by thought alone the body's
believing it's in that environmental
condition so if the environment signals
the gene and that's the truth
and the end product of an experiences in
the environment is an emotion
we're signaling the same genes and genes
make proteins and if you keep signaling
the same genes you start down regulating
the gene to make cheaper proteins and
the body begins to break down now
that's an unconscious process
so what goes along with that is the
moment the person feels that emotion of
unhappiness or whatever it is
uh the brain checks in with the body and
says yeah you're feeling pretty
miserable you're suffering and we tend
to generate more thoughts
equal to the feeling that we have
and so then we get caught in this loop
of thinking and feeling so if we can't
think
greater than how we feel
our feelings have become the means of
thinking
then we're thinking in the past right
and so we call that
the familiar past and then a person gets
going in the day and they start thinking
oh i gotta see this person i gotta go to
that meeting i hate doing this and now
they get in their routine
and a habit is a redundant set of
automatic unconscious thoughts behaviors
and emotions that's acquired through
repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind
so now the person
running through the same routine every
single day is on autopilot and their
body's now dragging them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists is the sweet spot of
the generous present moment that is when
the body and mind are free from those
conditions so along with those emotions
that influence the same thoughts
people start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled they start
getting more afraid more anxious more
depressed and now the body is literally
being depleted
of energy because it's believing that
it's living in an emergency situation
and in emergency you tap all the body's
resources for some threat whether it's
real or imagined and so then when you're
releasing all of these chemicals we are
literally drawing the body's life force
and turning it into chemistry and so for
the short term that's cool
but the arousal that's created from
those stress hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems
and the conditions in their life to
reaffirm their conditioning or their
addiction to that emotion
and in a sense they become addicted to
the life they don't even like
and this is why change is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay i'm not
going to say i can't i'm not going to
judge another person i'm not going to
blame i'm not going to complain i'm not
going to make excuses i'm not going to
be a victim i'm not going to talk trash
about anybody i'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours
then the body's saying you're out of
schedule you normally at 8 in the
morning you get in traffic and you're
angry then at 11 o'clock you check your
emails and you're really judgmental and
frustrated the body's saying well you've
been doing this for the last 20 years
you're just going to stop today so now
the body which has been conditioned
emotionally to be the mind wants to
return back to its familiar territory to
the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on
this is a good time to judge that come
on this is a good time to suffer it's
your ex's fault it's it's your it's the
government's fault it's uh
you know it's the weather what the news
whatever it is and if we
accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those pharmacy of
chemicals
and so that's when the person makes the
same choice
does the same thing
creates the same experience just for
that familiar feeling
okay i'll complain just so i can feel
suffering then
they'd rather
be unhappy
and step into the unknown to step into
possibility and the hardest part about
that process
first of all is not making the same
choice as you did day before
and here's the payoff
you got to stay conscious
and not go unconscious and it turns out
that 95 of the time we're unconscious so
if you're going to stay conscious then
there's an element that also requires a
certain amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so the thoughts that
they're thinking
are slipping by their awareness
unnoticed because they're hardwired in
their brain because they've been saying
i can't it's too hard my life will never
change it's someone else's fault those
thoughts have consequences in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious
of those unconscious thoughts becomes
aware of how they speak and how they act
and they notice
how they're feeling they're no longer
the program they're the consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
there are
when you when you're distracted by your
environment and you got your cell phone
and your tweeting and your
instagramming and facebook and whatever
people do you're distracted by that
feeling
but i now know that if you take a person
and you say okay close your eyes
sit in the in the silence of any
external stimulation remove the
environment sit your body down like an
animal body is the animal tell it to
stay i'm gonna feed you
you can check your cell phone you can
shower you can have your coffee but when
i say
and so then here comes the challenge
right so and and then
if you say then you're not gonna live in
the familiar future familiar past or
predictable future you're not going to
think about how long you've been
meditating what you got to do you you
labor
uh for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say i
think i'm meditating wrong i always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and
check your cell phone or have a cup of
coffee and you become aware that it's on
autopilot and wants to do that and you
say
come on over here
and you return it back to the present
moment
you're executing a will now
that's greater than the program and if
the person
wants to just get angry while they're
sitting there there's an arousal and
they notice the body is amping up and
revving up and they settle it back down
now they're telling the body it's no
longer the mind
that they're the mind now we've
researched this
and it's tedious
in the beginning at first because david
is fighting goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner or later the body is trained to a
new mind and when that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from the body as
energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life
and they're
they're working and lowering the volume
of that emotion the more they lower the
volume that emotion the more they're
going to take their attention off that
person and problem and they're going to
take their power back there's going to
be a break in their attention from that
circumstance and now they build their
own field and now there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because they've overcome their
old personality self so
i think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming
overcoming
overcoming overcoming until we become
somebody else when you think a
deliberate thought of what you want
then law of attraction will employ the
universe and all people circumstances
and events
to
move you to what you've asked for and to
move what you've asked for to you
and so
if if if you think about that
there is just action
would be really really hard for you to
reach all of the people circumstances
and events manipulate all of them
to receive what you want and if you
really reflect well on your life and
things that have happened in your life
you'll kind of see
that
actually that happened for me
ah all i did was move to here or all i
did was move to there and
i received what i wanted
thought creates all of the appearances
in the world and thought creates
everything in your life
so it's pretty darn powerful right
and what you think about is what you get
what you focus on is what will manifest
in your life and everyone is manifesting
their day every single day we're doing
it um we are not aware of course
necessarily of thoughts but
thoughts come we energize them and then
they will manifest unless we
cancel that thought out
um with another thought with a thought
that contradicts it but i remember
lester levinson would say
every single thought manifests
and i just thought that was incredible i
had known the secret for years and years
and years and lester levinson was a real
master
um and he said every single thought
manifests and i was just wow
that's how powerful they are
so
so thoughts are your superpower
to be do and have
what you want to experience and have and
do in your life
and and so if you ask
um an athlete or if you talk to a coach
a really brilliant coach right of a
sports team then you will find that
visualization and these principles that
i'm talking about are a big part of
their training
they have to be they have to see
themselves winning the game they have to
see themselves winning the match there
is a really incredible tennis player
that's a very big fan
a um a champion tennis player that's a
really big fan of the secret who uses
the sacred this is what he does he sees
that he's won the match before he walks
out onto that court
and and it's the same for
um
for teams it's the same for athletes in
the olympic games
running a race and seeing that they've
won yes they run the race but
what has them win the race is that
they saw themselves winning before they
even got on the starting block
and they saw it and believed it and felt
it and so they just everything lined up
for them in the perfect way they drew
the perfect lane everybody else was was
moved in exactly the right position and
they got a really great start and they
won the race
and so
thought is just so so powerful so
athletes but also do you know the
astronauts in the apollo um
program did visualization
before they went to the moon and
they visualized landing back on earth
safely
and so that's how important the
visualization visualization is just
thought in pictures by the way
it's it's it's still thought it's just
the same thing okay it's just thought in
pictures
so if you took a person who had
zero resistance
and you locked them in a room
you know if you took a person that had
zero resistance that person thought
about what they wanted zero resistance
lock them in a room what they wanted
will come to them
the universe will move people
circumstances and events and bring that
right to them
might be absolutely must
because if you have no resistance you
have unleashed a law that just cannot be
stopped
and so you will manifest it will come to
you many people come to me and say i
want to be a millionaire i i and there's
a great song about i'm going to be a
millionaire and they read things like
the secret which says if you want to be
a millionaire just just wish it and it
will happen
and that's not quite enough i've worked
with many many many millionaires and i
became on myself quite a long time ago
now never having possibly thought that
could ever happen when i was at school
i was going to be a nanny that's how
much i thought i could earn in my
lifetime that's what i thought i was
meant to be but then i worked with so
many multi-millionaires and billionaires
and i really understand
how to attract money how to attract
wealth i'm going to take you through
today
why you haven't yet become a millionaire
there's several things that will stop
you here's the number one
you don't believe you are worth it you
may want money you may long for money
but if you have an inner belief that
says i'm not worth it not only won't you
attract that money if you did you would
get rid of all of it so if you wish to
become a millionaire you must decide
you're worth it the more
reasons you can decide you're worth it
the more you'll have that motivation
that fire that drive to go out and make
a lot of money the second thing
that will make you become and stay a
millionaire
is working out how much good you will do
with the millions that you make you see
bill gates what an amazing guy he says
that in 20 years
malaria won't exist because he is using
his money
to wipe out malaria that's an
extraordinary thing and he deserves all
the wealth he has for that reason alone
if you can think of something that you
could do or
the people you would help an impact by
becoming a millionaire the more reasons
you can come up with the more people you
can help the more reasons you will have
to become and stay a millionaire and
here's the third thing and this is so
important many people think well i'm
just gonna float around and manifest
millions i'm just gonna sit at home with
my sofa and manifest millions if you
want a job you go out and look for a job
if you want a new home you go out and
visit new homes
you want a partner you better go out and
put yourself in front of people
and if you want to make and keep
millions
you need to decide what are you going to
do
to make those millions what gift or
talent do you have that you can monetize
you may say i don't have anything but
that's not true
if you really take a while you can find
a gift a unique skill set you have that
you could monetize you see some of the
smartest people in the world they don't
invent a product they take an existing
product like james dice and he took a
hair dryer
he took a fan heater he took a vacuum
cleaner he took a hand dryer and he made
them better
and many many people take an existing
product to make it better and become a
millionaire that way
it's not about shall i invent something
i don't have an inventive mind i'm not
creative
it's about an idea you may come up with
a new product you may take someone
else's product for instance shapewear
wasn't new when spanx came on the market
and became a
multi-multi-million dollar company they
didn't invent a new product well they
sort of did they took an existing
product they made it so much better
and you can do that too
but the biggest blocks i see with
budding millionaires are these things
one is
i'm going to be a millionaire i'm going
to be a millionaire and they just try
and imagine in the future and the thing
about the mind is the human mind doesn't
future pace very well
one of the reasons depressed people
can't snap out of it is because they
can't future pace and by the way if this
is making sense to you please like
please share please subscribe to my
channel show to other people who also
want to make money why wouldn't you want
to make money you can do great things
for others when you make money but they
don't know how they've been deluded by
these manifestation rooms sit at home
and chan on shanti and money will fall
from the heavens we all know
that's not true
so if you want money you must be able to
visualize but it must be now you must be
able to think of
how you're going to what could you
possibly do to make money remember that
woman who changed the face of a floor
mop they made a movie about her and she
became a millionaire and she was a
housewife but one day she was mopping
her floor you know this is not really a
good mark and she recreated and
reinvented a floor mop and
has made millions that way
but here's another big block you have to
work hard many people think well i'll
just manifest i just sit at home the
best plan in the world will not work
if you don't work so people get this
really weird belief that people who make
millions don't work they just manifest
it falls from the heavens they float
around doing a little stuff here and
there and that's not true i work with
millionaires and billionaires and they
do work hard they work long
and they work hard on their way to
success they work a lot when they get
success
of course they can take time out but you
see when you do what you love and love
what you do it never really feels like
work i love what i do
i do what i love often say i feel like
i've never worked a day in my life
because i love what i do but really
i have worked out when i've written
books i've been writing for 12 hours a
day meeting deadlines i travel all over
the world through time zones giving
talks and sometimes that's tiring i plan
out my schools and i'm there teaching
but i love it so much it doesn't feel
like work but if you believe
you can be a millionaire
and not have to change anything or do
anything or work hard you will probably
never be a millionaire
you have to work hard you have to apply
yourself the best plan will not work if
you don't you have to have phenomenal
extraordinary
self-belief
and finally you have to put yourself
around other people who've made money
ask them what did you do
what happened to you you see i met wayne
dyer many years ago and he said
something always remembered do not die
with your music still inside and i
thought wow
i'm one of the best therapists in the
world and i can't die with my therapy i
mean i need to create a course make a
school teacher to other people i was so
glad i listened to him
and i've listened to many people who say
the same thing i didn't go to university
i didn't have a child background i
wasn't born into money but i had a dream
a vision and i
married that vision to very hard work i
kept going
please don't think successfully will
never get rejected they do but they
bounce back they come back they have
unshakable
unwavering confidence they have drive
and determination
so take a few minutes and just get out a
little notebook or on your phone write
out all the reasons why you would like
to be a millionaire
all the good things you could do if you
were a millionaire the people you could
help
and then decide
what industry you could go into you're
going to invent something create
something
and some of the smartest people create
things entirely by mistake
look at what other millionaires have
done read some books written by
millionaires there are many
read richard branson reed felix dennis
look at some stories of millionaires and
decide if they can do it i can do it
this is a template
and i'm going to follow that template
and if you have the belief the vision
the work ethic the drive
and the confidence you will become a
millionaire
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome what
should you do when you first wake up
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there for all
of us you know and we've been
conditioned you know i mean you were
very fortunate because you you had a
a childhood where
you were
mind was open